60 the nature of epiphanies
we usually think of breakthroughs as
ecstatic moments that elevate us from a
lower level to a higher
and they do but there's a paradox
in the moment an epiphany feels like
hell
like roseanne cash's dream an epiphany
trashes us
it exposes us and leaves us naked we see
ourselves plain
and it's not a pretty picture the
essence of epiphanies is the stripping
away of self-delusion
we thought we were x now suddenly we see
we're
minus x where x divided by infinity
there's great power in this moment we've
lost something yes
a cherished self-delusion must be
abandoned and this hurts
but what we have gained is the truth our
[ __ ]
falls away the scales drop from our eyes
in that moment we have two options we
can reconstitute our [ __ ]
or we can turn pro
in the post-epiphanol moment we have two
things going for us that we didn't have
90
seconds earlier we have reality and we
have humility
these are powerful allies and we have a
third force working in our favor
shame why is shame good because shame
can produce the final element we need to
change our lives
will epiphanies hurt there's no glory to
them
they only make good stories at a a
meetings or late at night among other
foot soldiers in the trenches
these soldiers know each has his own
story
of that ghastly hideous excruciating
moment
when it all turned around for him